bonsoir à toutes et tous et bienvenue
sur France 24 c'est le journal de
l'Afrique voici les titres de ce lundi
26 décembre à la Une le coup d'envoi de
la campagne pour les législatives au
Bénin elles auront lieu le 8 janvier
prochain pour la première fois le parti
de l'ancien président Bonnie hayi
participe correspondant à suivre à la
Une également préservée à tout prix la
culture et le patrimoine juif en Tunisie
ne manquez pas notre reportage à Tunis à
l'occasion de la fête de Hanouka un
rendez-vous important vous le verrez
pour la communauté juive là-bas très
attachée à ces traditions et puis on
reviendra sur la situation en Gambie ou
le pouvoir a déclaré la semaine dernière
avoir déjoué un putsch militaire
plusieurs soldats ont été arrêtés on
fera le point dans ce journal avec le
journaliste barkaba
voilà pour les titres bienvenue sur
notre antenne initialement recalé il a
finalement été autorisé à concourir
c'était le mois dernier au Bénin le
parti de l'ancien Président Boni baptisé
les démocrates va bien prendre part au
législatif du 8 janvier c'est donc une
première depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir de
Patrice Talon c'était en 2016 sur place
la campagne et désormais ouverte
Emmanuel soggi et notre correspondante
dans le pays
c'est une campagne électorale qui
démarre très timidement sans doute en
raison du contexte des fêtes de fin
d'année mais c'est certain que la
ferveur ira crescendo au fur et à mesure
que l'on s'approchera du scrutin cette
partie dont quatre de la mouvance
présidentielle sont en compétition c'est
législatives seront très scrutés car
c'est la première fois depuis l'arrivée
au pouvoir de Patrice Talon que le
principal parti d'opposition pourra
participer à une élection depuis 2016 le
parti de l'ancien chef de l'État il y
aboni n'a jamais réussi à remplir les
critères exigés par la nouvelle loi
électorale pour aller aux différentes
élections actuellement tous les députés
au Parlement sont tous dans le camp
présidentiel c'est d'ailleurs un des
thèmes de campagne de l'opposition qui
dénonce une dérive démocratique de leur
côté depuis le lancement de la campagne
et bien elle est partie du président
talon défendent l'action du gouvernement
et de toutes cylisation au plan
économique et social durant 6 ans alors
vous le voyez c'est législatives sont
plus fiables pour cela lui permettra de
mesurer son poids dans les urnes on aura
aussi la réponse à d'autres questions
qui se pose est-ce que le pouvoir
gardera sa majorité absolue au Parlement
ou bien encore est-ce que ces élections
vont se transformer en un référendum
pour ou contre talons après 6 ans du
gouvernance réponse à la mi-janvier au
moment du scrutin
on en vient à cette nouvelle explosion
dans l'est du Burkina Faso cette fois
c'est un mini bus qui a sauté sur une
mine au moins 10 passagers des civils
ont trouvé la mort 5 autres ont été
blessés et plusieurs autres sont eux
portés disparus toujours samedi déjà
deux soldats d'unité de patrouille avait
été tué par l'explosion là également
d'un engin explosif
au Niger l'armée elle aussi étendue
après le crash meurtrier de l'un de ses
hélicoptères l'accident est survenu
alors que l'appareil revenait d'un vol
d'entraînement il s'est écrasé lors de
son atterrissage sur la piste militaire
de l'aéroport de Niamey les trois
membres d'équipage n'ont pas survécu une
commission d'enquête a été chargée de
déterminer les causes de cet incident
elles achève ce lundi tout autre chose à
présent la fête de Hanouka est un moment
important pour la communauté juive des
juifs dont le nombre a fondu il faut le
dire en Tunisie de 100 000 dans les
années 50 à environ 1200 1600 peut-être
aujourd'hui d'où la nécessité pour eux
de se battre pour conserver ce
patrimoine religieux mais aussi
culturelle unique en songeant reportage
à Tunis pour France 24 il est signé
l'ilia Blaise avec Hamdi Lili
à la synagogue de la Goulette à Tunis
cette poignée de croyants est comme une
famille les derniers Juifs de la
capitale célèbre Hanouka autour de leur
rabbin Daniel Cohen
[Applaudissements]
un moment de communion et de
dégustations
l'huile a une symbolique car le miracle
de Hanouka est basé sur un fiole d'huile
à Tunis cette fête est un acte de
résistance pour une communauté qui
compte aujourd'hui 300 personnes
du petit et aujourd'hui en Tunisie on
est une toute petite communauté donc
c'est toujours beaucoup d'espoir de
fêter cette fête en Tunisie parce que
c'est c'est l'espoir de la minorité
due à l'exode massif des juifs tunisiens
vers l'Europe dans les années 60 mais
également de la montée de courant
extrémistes après la révolution de 2011
il a eu des menaces
sur des Juifs sur les intellectuels sur
les femmes et évidemment aujourd'hui je
pense que l'État est en train de jouer
sans son rôle nous considérons qu'il est
de notre devoir n'est pas un devoir de
mémoire mais un devoir d'histoire une
histoire que certains jeunes retrouvent
avec émotion comme Camille Lévy
franco-tunisienne juive sa famille a
quitté la Tunisie il y a deux
générations nous l'avons suivi lors de
la dernière veillée de Hanouka à la
synagogue il y a vraiment ce désir de
déconstruire ce qu'on nous a enseigné et
essayer de comprendre ce qui s'est passé
et de renouer le lien avec celle avec ce
pays ou cette région que nos
grands-parents ou nos parents ont quitté
de manière
un peu dramatique
dimanche soir le rabbin a laissé Camille
et d'autres femmes allumer une bougie de
la Menorah tradition habituellement
réservée aux hommes un acte d'ouverture
dans un pays où la femme a toujours été
précurseur
c'était mercredi dernier le gouvernement
gambien assuré avoir des jouets un coup
d'État militaire tenté la veille bilan
selon les autorités 5 personnalités dont
4 soldats toutes sont donc accusés
d'avoir voulu renverser à dama barreau
arrivé pour rappel au pouvoir en 2017
pour en parler nous sommes en ligne avec
barkaba bonsoir merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation vous êtes journaliste
et analyste politique l’enquête se
poursuit en Gambie vous pouvez nous en
dire plus sur le déroulé de cette
tentative de coup d'état mardi 20
décembre
effectivement le gouvernement d'un bien
a annoncé la découverte d'un complot
pour renverser le gouvernement du
président Adama Baro en annonçant
l'arrestation de dans un premier temps
de 4 officiers et
de recherche engagées contre d'autres
militaires soupçonnés d'avoir pris part
à cette tentative de coup d'État dans la
même foulée un ancien ministre des
Affaires étrangères sous le régime de
qui a relié le parti ubi qui est la
principale formation de l'opposition
avez aussi été interpellé dans le cadre
de cette supposée tentative de le coup
d'être d'où ma prochaine question
certains observateurs en Gambie lis
cette tentative de putsch militaire à
l'ancien chef de l'État vous l'avez
mentionné Yaya Jamme actuellement en
exil en Guinée équatoriale il aurait
toujours le soutien d'une partie de
l'armée qu'en est-il exactement
le président Yaya est parti prenante ou
pas de cette tentative de coup d'état ce
qui est par contre certains c'est le
contexte dans lequel ces accusations
sont intervenues les interpellations
effectuées contre les soldats présumés
72 heures après des appels WhatsApp lors
d'une réunion avec une partie des
fidèles de Yaya de son parti les filles
assis qui est divisé en dépendance où il
y a djamé déclaré qu'il allait rentrer
en Gambie et défier les acteurs
autorités en disant que personne ne peut
empêcher son retour en Gambie c'est 72
heures après cette déclaration de Yaya
Diamé que les soldats
ont été interpellés et le profil aussi
un truc parce que ce ne sont pas du tout
des officiers supérieurs mais plutôt la
plupart d'entre eux sont des soldats
durant dont l'un des plus gradés
seraient voilà donc un pour l'identité
le profil des personnalités Adama Baro
lui est arrivé au pouvoir on le rappelle
en 2017 qui a marqué la fin de 22 ans de
dictature sous yahyajamé et le nouveau
président a fait de la réforme des
services de sécurité une priorité bien
sûr c'est tout sauf une mince affaire ça
peut expliquer également ces vivants
de règne ça laisse une forte empreinte
et il y a également
assez particulier une partie de la
hiérarchie de l'armée gambienne lui doit
son ascension et ce n'est que de manière
très timide que l'actuel président dans
mon bureau a essayé d'opérer des
changements et ce n'est pas pour rien
qu'il est encore presque sous le
parapluie sécuritaire de la CEDEAO avec
le déploiement d'une force de sécurité
dont l'essentiel est composé par les
troupes du grand frère sénégalais du
voisin sénégalais qui a déployé sur
place un contingent de près de 625
hommes vous qui connaissez bien le pays
et la région vous avez été surpris par
cette tentative de coup d'État militaire
c'est un pays la Gambie ou le terrain
est propice en tout cas ces dernières
années à ce genre d'événement
du pays qui a déjà connu dans les années
80 des tentatives de stabilisation de la
part de pourquoi il semble et ensuite
après le but de
1994 il n'est pas étonnant que de temps
en temps qu'il y ait des sous-dossaux
mais globalement depuis l'élection et la
réélection intervenues l'année dernière
du président
même si sur le plan économique tout
n'est pas rose et que le chômage des
jeunes surtout et le coût d'un navire
restent très élevé pour les gardiens la
gamme restait relativement stable mais
le contexte de la sous-région avec la
contagion pretorielle qu'on voit avec
les poutres au Mali en Guinée et au
Burkina Faso bel et bien donner des
idées à des gens pour tenter une
aventure et comme dans les pays que vous
avez cité vous CRA créer désormais que
la démocratie gambienne en prenne un
coup c'est de très mauvais augures
là-bas
[Musique]
parce que
depuis son règne en arabe a vu effectuer
des tours dans les dans les cases que la
température de coupe d'État soirée ou
pas je pense que c'est une série Alerte
pour son régime et
prioritairement parmi ces chantiers doit
s'engager une performance en profondeur
du du secteur de sécurité et que le
parapluie de la CEDEAO et du voisin
Sénégalais ne pourra pas elle fait
d'abord assurer sa propre sécurité
barkaba invité du journal de l'Afrique
sur France 24 merci beaucoup d'avoir
répondu à mes questions ce soir voilà
donc un pour ce point sur la situation
en Gambie moins d'une semaine après
cette tentative de coup d'état des
jouets par le pouvoir c'est la fin de
cette édition merci à kalidouci qui
était en régie pour la réalisation de
cette édition merci également aux
équipes techniques sans qu'ils rien ne
serait possible à rester avec nous
l'information continue sur France 24
[Musique]